depuis des mois le chaos règne en Haïti
le gouvernement ne contrôle plus grand
chose ce sont eux des gains criminels
qui ont pris possession de plusieurs
endroits stratégiques
[Applaudissements]
que le Canada est d'autres pays
s'engagent pour aider en Haïti et on se
retrouve encore une fois dans une
situation de catastrophe mais pas
question pour l'instant d'intervenir
directement sur le terrain le Canada 13
ouvert à jouer un rôle important mais
nous devons avoir un consensus
haïtien à quelques kilomètres de là à
peu près au même moment François Legault
rencontré le président de la Tunisie un
autre pays qui a attiré l'attention
internationale Casey aide à suspendu la
Constitution il a dissout le Parlement
et ordonné des élections le 17 décembre
François Legault assure lui avoir fait
part de ses préoccupations
un sommet avec près d'une centaine
d'états c'est aussi une occasion
d'ouvrir des portes devant le forum
économique de la Francophonie François
Legault répète qu'il veut augmenter les
échanges commerciaux avec la France
notamment on est supposé des frères des
cousins après ça comme vous voudrez
5 milliards d'échanges commerciaux par
année comme on dit au Québec c'est des
pinotes François LEGO est ainsi devenu
le démarcheur en chef du Québec il
avorté ses ressources naturelles son
électricité et sa position stratégique
comme porte d'entrée du marché
nord-américain ici Sébastien Bover
Radio-Canada au sommet de la
Francophonie à Djerba en Tunisie